يتساءل البعض الآن كيف سيكون
رد فعل رئيسي ترامب في حال خسارته في
نوفمبر ، هل فكرت يومًا في ما
سيحدث إذا ظهرت نتائج الانتخابات
على أنك الفائز
ورفض ترامب ترك نعم ، لقد
خطرت أيضًا في ذهن الوسيط السابق لترامب.
أخشى أنه إذا خسر الانتخابات في
عام 2020 ، فلن يكون هناك انتقال سلمي للسلطة أبدًا ،
لذا إذا حدث
ذلك ، فإن ما سيحدث بعد ذلك سيكون أفضل تخميني
إذا خسر الانتخابات
وأنت تعلم أنه يفعل أي
طعن أمام المحكمة سيفعله  وفشلوا جميعًا
، سيؤدي رئيس جديد اليمين الدستورية اعتبارًا
من 20 يناير من العام المقبل ، وبعد
ذلك سيتحكم هذا الشخص في
الجيش ووزارة العدل
وجميع روافع الحكومة ويفترض
أنه سيأمر بإقالته من
البيت الأبيض و  الشخص الوحيد الذي
يمكن أن يكون ذلك الرئيس الجديد يوافق ،
وأعدك بأنني مقتنع تمامًا
بأنهم سيرافقونه من البيت الأبيض
في نسخة مع إرسال كبير ،
حسنًا.  ProjectSyndicate ar ولكن ماذا لو فاز ترامب في
تشرين الثاني (نوفمبر) وما زلت مرة أخرى بموجب
القواعد العادية ، سأخرج في عام 2024 ، لذلك
قد نضطر إلى الذهاب لفترة إضافية مات فرانكلين روزفلت
خلال فترة ولايته الرابعة ، لكن
طول عمره أدى إلى التعديل الثاني والعشرين
الذي يحد الآن  زعيم أمريكا العزيز
لفترتين فقط أنا دونالد جون ترامب
يمكن أن يغير أنه سيتطلب
تعديلاً دستوريًا ، لقد حدث
التعديل الثامن عشر الذي حظر المشروبات الكحولية في
عام 1919 مثل برميل
بوربون في عام 1933 ،
لذا سيحتاج الرئيس ترامب الأول
ثلثي الكمية  مجلس النواب ومجلس الشيوخ أو 2/3 من
الولايات لاقتراح التعديل ، ثم
يجب أن تصدق 3/4 من الولايات
وكل ذلك يتطلب موجة حمراء كبيرة حقًا
تأتي في نوفمبر
، ثم هل من الممكن أن
يحدث ذلك 27 مرة في  تاريخنا منذ عام
1789 كان هناك 27
تعديلاً دستوريًا ناجحًا ولكن هذا من
بين ما يقرب من 12000 اقتراح
تم تقديمه في الكونجرس